[Musik]
meine damen und herren herzen kommt zu
einem neuen video jana ist an meiner
seite leute und das heißt heute gibt es
die fortsetzung von songs nach ganzen
challenge der zweite teil kommt heute ja
ich werde gegen eine antreten songs
nachtanzen dass unsere jury da drüben
haben wir gute ideen in der mitte haben
wir ja klein rot alice cooper die
bereisen selbstständig absolute musik
und tanz experten und werden deswegen
versuche zu erraten was wir davor tanzen
und unsere aufgabe ist es möglichst
eindeutig durchtanzen ausdrücken welchen
song man gerade hört ganz kurz noch
verzichten wir sind mit seinem
hotelzimmer wir sind gerade auf dem
splash und ihr müsst ja auch genau aus
passion ja dazu müsste doch bis heute
haben nur 20 sekunden zeit zu tanzen
können wir sind hier mitmachen und es
könnte virtuell ein bisschen panisch
werden
[Musik]
ich habe mir die indicated die politik
[Applaus]
soll man von otto wolff
startzeiten leute können so auch ganz
sicher sein dass wir nicht länger als
eine weitere nacht im hotel bleiben
ich habe einen aber was jetzt mache es
bisschen unfair und erst machen
doch unfair jetzt weil es unfair ist
dann kriegst du keinen punkt dafür dass
leute es geht das ankommt oder es ist
die disqualifizierung
das video das auf jeden fall nicht auch
das geschlecht hat schlechte auswahl
das war schon der zweite dieser art
diesmal war es einfach zu viel sagt
einfach ist
[Musik]
das video on demand service bekannt
wie willi emsland die unterhaltung
werden gut schlecht somit nun ja
schlechte stimmung schlecht ist die
stimmung jetzige zickzack ja schlecht
[Musik]
khalifa kommt ihr nicht aber ich habe
keine ahnung wer dann sag mal was ihr
denkt gibt es hat ja auch gesagt ich
habe gedacht den schrank dann gehen
scheint was wir uns jetzt ein schwank
mit der eu zu verkünden ja wir waren
doch jetzt alter okay ganz kurz gemacht
dass hier und das hier
[Musik]
damit dieses jesus plätze dort dieses
wies der sommer da war nix gegen kommen
ribery war das zu lästig das war das
tollste lässig war dann eben wieder her
mit unserem sondern mehr raten okay weil
es ein video von partie gewinnen also
wir dürfen sachen einsetzen die hier im
zimmer um linear ok wird du mir nicht
deswegen schon wieder keine punkte aber
[Musik]
voller mir ja sogar ohne mir gesagt dass
es nicht für die euroleague
so lassen wie beim kunstprojekt ich
danke kunden
[Musik]
da kommt dann meiner sollte die single
seit drei jahren hat immer jemand für
die zahlen muss ja auch aus vorbereiten
ok hatte dafür brauche ich keine
unterstützung gestellt wohin stand also
ich sag mal so viel ist ein deutscher
klassiker es geht los
[Musik]
das lied ist ja schlimm die schützenhaus
die du liebst im mercedes und sein
bruder
ich liebe das auch das oberhaupt im juli
verkündet dass abflugort also das urteil
war ganz kurz foto reflex ich könnt ihr
das hier anbieten
aber mein auto ich könnte das ja ja ja
ja ja die leute für das hast du schon so
weit ich habe euch hier drüber und
vergoss geht verlegt da hab ich mit den
doobie brothers zusammen ein open air
kino selbst gebaut aus
haushaltsgegenständen jackson
verfolgerin